It's time for Drew's News,
your joy ride down Good News Falls.
And with me at the desk is two besties
I'd love to hop in a barrel
and float on down the river with.
It's Cameron Auntie PooPoo Diaz.
And Rossy Ross Matthews.
And together they make Auntie Rossy Poo.
All right, PooPoo, I want to dedicate this segment to you.
When I was trying to, basically,
let's face it, it was an audition.
And I really felt strongly about this particular segment.
It was very personal for me,
but to convince everybody of this idea,
I had to put it in the sales tape and sell this segment.
So of course, I'm gonna take you back
to that audition sales tape.
Let's look back at the very first Drew's News in history.
The one thing I don't like doing with you
is hiking because you have these giant
great like German shepherds and you
have these long legs.
You are a great Dane.
And I have these short dogs
and the legs of a corgi dog.
And I literally can't keep up with you.
No it's, it's a kind of a comedy act.
I look back, she's like,
(Cameron makes hissing breathing sounds)
She's like seething, her face, she's just so angry at me.
I know, I can't keep up.
I have to stop every five seconds.
I'm like, come on, let's go, what's the matter?
It's like a gazelle and an armadillo.
That's what us hiking looks like.
(audience applauds)
So thank you for helping me
convince everyone of this segment.
My pleasure.
It was my pleasure.
(audience applauds)
It was a hard sell, and you know,
I also think when it came to that banter,
that comradery, that bouncing off each other,
talking about the news stories
and then sharing feelings and opinions about it,
when you're alone, you don't have anyone to do that with.
So Rossy Ross Matthews,
thank God showed up and saved a girl.
(audience applauds)
The best partner in the world.
Cameron you're here.
Will you go through some stories with us today?
Yes I would love to.
All right, let's hit it.
First up some breaking news from the
international house of pancakes.
Yeah, we bring you the stories you want to know.
USA Today reports, IHOP has some new menu items
for your next bestie brunch.
Bubbles, wine and brews.
That's right.
Alcohol is on the menu at IHOP,
officially making them the
international house of pound, pound, pound.
Oh my God, IHOP, you know how I love brunch.
Brunch is a way of life for me,
but I'm just worried at IHOP when you're drinking,
it's going to be go from, IHOP to I wasted,
to I drunk texted my ex,
to I hate myself in the morning, you know?
That's a really slippery slope.
It sounds like profit for IHOP.
Ding ding ding.
Well, you know, I have an suggestion for IHOP,
as you boost your sales,
nothing goes with a big old stack of buttermilk pancakes,
like a crisp, refreshing glass of wine,
that's clean organic and from wine maker, Cameron Diaz.
(audience applauds)
She is selling the product.
I know, she's my she's like my support here.
My biggest supporter.
Well, you know, I'd like you to
quickly tell everyone else what you told me,
because you made me realize
that I didn't know about wine.
Sure.
So my partner, my co-founder Katherine Power and I,
we love to drink wine and we were drinking wine one day
and realized that, you know,
everything else in our life we're leveling up on,
we, everything we drink eat is organic.
And we just realized we never questioned what was in wine,
and sort of naively thinking that it was
just fermented grapes.
And then we sort of took this deep dive into wine making.
And we really found out that there is
over 73 ingredients that can be added to wine
without any disclosure.
And so we kind of just made clean, delicious wine.
So we don't add any extra sugar.
We don't add any colors or concentrates.
It's all organic.
And we made first and foremost delicious wine.
Am I correct?
The only thing I am upset about this wine with
is that I don't have enough.
So let me just, here.
Oh yeah, okay.
Here we go.
Cheers.
It's actually glass, you guys.
Okay.
Whoa!
That was a big gulp.
That is so good.
IHOP, it's called Avaline.
Wow.
Cameron, it's your story.
Okay, thank you.
My turn, okay.
So there's a new trend in dating we have to talk about
In Style reports it's called hard balling.
Ooh.
Ouch.
I mean, I like it already.
Whoa.
And it's, this is the definition of it, okay?
So don't get so crazy, okay.
And it's when you treat your dating life,
like you're running a fortune 500 company
and you're the CEO of that company
and you make hard decisions and you make them fast.
So anyone who doesn't meet your criteria has got to go.
Ross.
Yeah.
I think you should treat it like a business.
If you're not what I'm looking for,
get out, next, move on.
But I also think there's a time in people's lives
where you should play a little softball
if you know what I mean.
Like just, just have some fun.
I have a girlfriend who kept saying,
I keep, these guys keep leaving me.
They keep leaving me.
I go, well, what are the first dates like?
She says, well, I ask them if they want kids.
I asked them, I'm like, girl,
what are you doing on date one?
You don't ask if you want kids.
You ask if you like pizza or the color blue.
So she was a natural hard baller from the beginning
because she's like, this is what I want.
Are you in?
No.
So she shouldn't be looking at it
that they're leaving her.
She should be going, you know what?
You don't add up to me.
You don't, you're not my, you're not at my place,
but that's okay.
That's okay.
Then you at least know, you know what I mean?
At least, you know, like we're not in the same place.
And I think that's what dating is all about.
I hear you.
I hear it.
I think it's just important to know what you want,
and when you see it, hold on to it.
And if you find something that's not for you,
don't be afraid to move on.
Don't be afraid to leap onto the unknown
because you'll find what you need eventually.
And mostly if the other person
is not holding onto you, let go of them.
Okay, ding, ding.
That part, yes queen.
Been there.
That might be my favorite piece of advice
that came out of this.
All right.
Next, Cameron.
I have a TikTok video that I want to show you.
Take a look.
If you don't have ear buds, okay?
It's hard.
It's hard to talk on the phone.
It just keeps on falling out.
So I go old school, analog.
Let's get involved.
You got to plug it in.
It's now wireless.
Um, PooPoo, can you name that person?
Tom Cruise.
Okay, so you see Tom Cruise?
Yes.
Okay.
That is not Tom Cruise.
It's actually this new thing.
It's called the deep fake.
CNN business reports that there are dozens
of these deep fake Tom Cruise videos,
and they've gotten millions and millions
of views on TikTok.
But they were actually made by a visual effect artist,
in this case, Chris Ume,
using artificial intelligence, CGI
and a real actor.
What?
That's terrifying.
I know.
And the reason that I wanted to bring this up
is because there's a lot of misinterpreters out there,
a lot of misinformation.
And you may think someone is saying something out there
or being someone or doing something,
but it's actually not that person.
So Chris says that with his work with celebs like Tom,
it's just for fun, and he just wanted to do videos
that he had, you know, were having fun with
and he'd take them down and he's removing them.
But let's just be aware of deep fakes.
Let's know they exist.
So we can empower ourselves
that if we see something that's questionable,
we question it.
And you know, if you ever see a video of me
ripping down the highway, flipping people the bird
out of my window in my minivan,
that's not a deep fake.
That's real.
I drive a minivan and I have road rage,
so live with it.
Most importantly, I just want to say
if anybody ever does this for me,
just put me on a face with a better jaw line, okay?
Thank you.
Oh hey, and before we go,
parents love embarrassing their kids just for sport.
Do you ever do that?
No?
Oh no, I would never do that to my child.
Okay.
Well just wait until they go to college, okay?
'Cause the gold medal for this
goes to David and Whitney Scott from Arkansas.
When their daughter moved to college this fall,
Fox news reports that they gave her
a giant blanket with their faces on it.
Right?
Just to embarrass them at school.
This, I mean, save your money.
Nobody wants this gift.
I'd rather have a gift with Tom Cruise's face on it, okay?
You and me both.